[Music]
welcome to simply learn we are honored
to have you join us today for break free
from traditional cells with digital
selling with our special guest Lela :
if you do not know Lila Bullock Lena
comes to a highly revered she is
regarded as Grace Forbes and a number 10
Downing Street and her with her presence
she's a highly connected and influential
serious entrepreneur she has she was
crowned the social influence of Europe
by Oracle and as a recipient of the
global woman champions award by the
global connection for woman foundation
for her outstanding contribution
leadership and business
Lila has regularly mentioned in Forbes
telegraph wires prema magazine Sunday
Times The Guardian Cosmetics social
media today and Radio 5 Alive she also
has a number one top seller book on
Amazon and sellers and marketing is
often mentioned in Forbes along with the
other number of other media I do when
they special mention of simply learn for
hosting these webinars simply learn the
most credible training provider for the
digital age global online training
leader with over 500,000 attendees
working with over 2,000 enterprises over
400 courses because of the highly
engaged blending learning model has a
highest course completion rate in the
industry simply learn is truly the
leader in global online training share
your experience here in social media if
you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful sharing your
social channels Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter you can use the hashtag SL
webinars that way people can find it and
you'll make them wish they were here so
go ahead and sit back relax have a cup
of coffee tea or if it's evening for
your at maybe a glass of wine if you
like me you might be sharpening your
pencil to take notes and enjoy you
didn't come here to listen to me I'm on
to hand this over to our guest speaker
today hello Lila Lila welcome to today's
webinar
can you see my screen see I have yes you
should be up there that looks like the
interest Green is up fantastic okay
thank you very much for joining as well
and in this webinar I'm going to be
showing you how to break free from
traditional sales and white imperative
that you do so right now you're going to
learn about digital selling as well as
facial selling and their evolution over
time as well as about the current issues
with digital learning furthermore we go
into more detail about what digital
selling and social selling entail what
their basics are and how you can get
started but also be discussing using
tools and technology that are needed as
part of your digital sewing journey and
finally we'll end it all off with any
questions that you may have so just a
tall laptop keyboard will straight out a
pen and paper to start taking notes and
if you have any questions let me down so
that we can discuss more at the end of
this webinar we may live in a very
different world when it comes to fair
just think about it twenty to thirty
years or so ago what do you need you to
buy something you're most likely rely on
your friends and family asking them what
they use what they think impacting where
you'll go to store directly to be
convinced by an enthusiastic salesperson
now though it's much easier for the
consumer there's still care what their
friends and family have trained and that
store likely to ask them first but what
will ultimately help them make their
decision is the internet the Internet
has a multitude of consequences on
decision making and buying processes for
example it helped make us more informed
consumers if we're thinking of getting a
new digital tool for example we can
spend days researching all the major
players compare all their features
easily compare prices with all
competitors in various trim
reviews regular people proper forms and
any other channel we can find and while
sure that everyone goes through this
whole research process we're making a
new purchase the reality is that
consumer is more important than ever
before the point is they have access to
this knowledge and in many cases they
also use this especially of the b2c to
be company when you're targeting
informed educated and Windley just by
all of this many sales people are very
much still living in the past why would
you call call a consumer by the one we
talked about and the main record for
reaching out to lead I would you give
them the same spiel that they can easily
find online probably on your very own
website the thing is people in South are
still overwhelmingly in the same world
and job even though that's not where the
action is any longer
there are over 2.5 billion people on
social networks have over a third of the
entire world population but numbers like
these is easy to see why the present the
future of selling happens online and yet
research shows that two-thirds of
companies don't have any social media
strategies that their penalty
not to say that traditional self
techniques don't work to any longer what
it does mean is that many fail people
are overlooking the huge potential the
digital world brings and that they are
losing opportunity to their competition
when they disregard for digital spelling
digital selling is the process of using
leveraging digital channel to discover
profit and sales opportunities in order
to nurture them return into custom
social selling to put it simply is what
social media marketing is to digital
marketing basically social selling is
digital selling using social media
platform social media has changed so
much about how we communicate with each
other as well as how businesses interact
with consumers and potential consumers
and much of social media in fact but the
Internet in general and all that entails
blogs YouTube forum email and so on
those people need to three ways to eat
their leads wherever they are in the
customer journey and because we are all
online that means that self people need
to be only digital channels as well if
they want to be competitive in this
market one of the most important things
to understand about digital and social
selling if it's not about making your
usual self pitches only on a different
platform rather it's a way to generate
and nurturing and provide them with
content that takes them one two or
however many steps forward in their
decision-making process
when I first got introduced to social
media in a serious way over a decade ago
the world was very different to where it
now so many people believe social media
to be a fad and even more fail to see
the potential for businesses people are
reticent and it took very long time that
that the world has changed and that
ironies for the foreseeable future
people use social media and the Internet
in general as a platform for
communication not just the friend zone
but also for meeting new people learning
using interacting with brands getting
their news and much more I still
remember how difficult it was a decade
ago to convince businesses the
importance of a digital presence and
even though I believe here even if I
didn't react as far things would come in
a very short time the history of
evolution of digital planet is quite
short although the Internet has been
around longer than most of us expect it
took time to make this technology
accessible to the entire world and it
took even longer for Graham to start
using it properly only walk you through
some of the most important date and
accomplishment in your digital marketing
the parable introduced close to 30 years
ago in 1990 Google has been introduced
eight years later in 1998 and whether as
a few years it managed to wipe out most
foreign search engines next social
networks started popping up lengthen was
launched in 2002 my place into family
Facebook in 2004 YouTube in 2005 and
Twitter in 2006 at this point
branding completely grew up what was
happening around them they weren't sure
if this was a fast if there's any use
for businesses but still some of them
tried for example Universal Music
created their first ever mobile
marketing survey all the way back in
2001 60 years before the first iPhone
was launched by 2012 markets have
started to see the potential in social
media with budgets increased 64% sir
there was nowhere near the same room as
where we are today only five years later
right now we have a multitude of
channels to use to communicate and
interact with our audience and not only
do we have this possibility but it's
also pretty much a necessity to stay
competitive in this world
for example b2b marketers use an average
of 6 channels to distribute their
content right one of them subtle
only years ago just take a look at
Domino's
right at this moment there's probably
someone in a world who is using a
facebook Messenger app to order a team
suck on them as quickly as possible
but they're short history lessons fail
to show how competitive the digital
world has become
he failed to show us how big the
audience is now and how much that to
have changed and evolved
the main thing to understand about
digital marketing and digital spelling
now is that it's all about the consumer
it's about being where a consuming use
and offering them the content that they
want to read see here and it's about
performing our branded content to
generate leads nurture them and turn
into customers the big problem here
though is that generally that is a big
disconnect between the sale team and
marketing and digital teens before
they've made them the marketing team did
their thing purchase them has created
from balance and so on anything to get
the word out about the business they
were promoting customers various people
handled all the calls coming in from
customers and try to sort them and
finally the felting handled talking to
prospect and potential customer and
closed and do even though all of these
different departments
works for the same common goal there was
little to no interaction collaboration
between the departments everyone did
their thing and that was that
unfortunately the funded with that is
still decay there's still a disconnect
between departments and that is the
problem because the world must have you
changed you might have heard of
omni-channel market if you haven't to
give you a short explanation of a
channel marketing is all about offering
a seamless consumer experience no matter
what channel or device the consumer
might be using only channel marketing is
for all intents and purposes the future
it's what customers want and what they
demand they want a business that is
available 24/7 on all the channels and
devices they use and they want to get a
positive and CMS experience across all
while being channels and devices they
use but
can they get back when your digital
marketing team has little to no
knowledge of sales
what if they have questions about your
products for sharing interesting buying
from you and then when they go to answer
a couple of questions about your product
on Twitter that face is not answers to
give them no help and no direction to
prompt a decision for your target
audience is going to use whatever tackle
may prefer to interact with me and if
you're not ready to sell to them to
convince them to bond you are losing
them the potential customer but that's
not the only issue and it's not just
about those cases when people come
directly to you to ask a question social
media and other digital platforms are
able to the brim with possibilities and
opportunities if you're not only ready
to prospect nurture and convert your
audience then they were likely to lose
your competitive edge Digital selling
isn't the next big thing it is currently
the big thing in fact it's barely a
decision anymore for businesses that is
what your customer wants and demand so
there's really no choice to be made on
whether to adopt digital selling or not
if both the present and the future and
only those who are able to adapt will be
able to stay competitive in their
respective industry digital selling has
pre named em first there's awareness the
stage and once you introduce your brand
to the customer and they slowly become
familiar with it basically is about than
hearing about you following you on
social media or your blog and
interaction with you with digital
channels next this consideration the
stage in which the prospect is learning
even more about you and your business
and starting to consider this is the
stage where digital spending really
shining this is when you interact with
the lead and nurture them so that you
can get to the last day
the transaction if final stage is when
old-school sales tactic top their
heading the leaders put into contact
with a salesperson so they can finalize
the transaction and turn them into
paying content the first one the most
important stages in digital selling in
listening and research great digital
selling you're quite a lot of different
as we know is taken you at this stage
you need to research your audience and
understand their needs their struggles
their interest aspirations and so on the
good news is your audience is most
likely online and that means that you
can find a plethora of valuable
information about them quite easily all
you need is web monitoring tool and you
can get sorted such as brand24 connect
insight and r and watch all of you tools
allow you to monitor the entire web such
as social media channel form blog news
website and so on are using iterative
you will be able to understand more
about your audience and their interests
and preferences which all that'll help
you create better digital content and a
better digital planning strategy plus it
will also help you identify the top
social influencer of your audience is
listening to as well as your brand
advocate and as you continue using web
listening tools your sales people can
also use them to discover cost
effectively and then use your brand
digital channels to engage them and
nurture them another important element
of digital 7 is being where your
audiences your business needs to be
present on news channel whether it be
Facebook Twitter Linkedin blogging
platforms or all of the above so that
you can engage your audience and nurture
them by doing all of this listening and
research they have a much better
understanding of where your audience is
spending their time online as well as
what content they put
and once and finally the last big stage
of digital selling is customer
engagement at this stage is all about
communication and interaction with the
lead
this can happen on multiple channels and
platform which is another reason why
it's so important that there is a strong
collaboration between all of your
departments that deal with customers and
needs in any way shape or form the
conversation with a lead very well start
on Tata with a direct message continue
on Facebook with some on page engagement
with your brand followed up by some
email and finally with a sales cool
there are all kinds of routes your
customer interactions to take what's
important is that you are there and that
you are able to continue the
conversation organically most important
element of digital filling for Weber is
the content you create and publish on
your different digital channel digital
content marketing and all that entails
social media blogging and so on is now
employed by tackling 91% of businesses
to business marketers however business
is often fire including yourself people
in their content marketing strategy
which is incredibly important the
digital selling although this is
changing is more and more marketed by
producing the content in half there
still needs to be a much bigger focus on
involving sales people in the content
marketing
in order to be a better digital seller
and stand out from the crowd you need to
focus more of your resources into
creating highly targeted and
personalized content that serves a very
clear purpose there is simply too much
competition for audiences attention so
one of the best ways to stand out and
get your slice of the pie is to create
this type of content this is where all
that research web monitoring comes in
handy it helps you understand who forms
your audience what their interests and
their needs are what they are spire to
what type of content they consume and
engage with and so on demographics is
simply not cutting it any longer now if
all about producing the right
personalized content delivered at
exactly the right time on social media
blog or website or an email and any
other digital platform or channel if you
want to get more involved in digital
phone you own of course need to set up
some tools and software after all it
makes sense but if you want to succeed
in the digital world you need technology
to help the essential tools that you'll
need are a social media management tool
a customer relationship management tool
a web monitoring and listening to
marketing automation and in half
communication tool first of all you need
to create an environment where in all of
your different departments and framing
and easily collaborate between them as I
mentioned earlier yourself who needs to
be more involved in a content creation
process as well as in any digital
engagement happening with potential
needs so it's essential to make it as
easy as possible for them to collaborate
get it all like black or Zoho click to
make communication easy then your entire
business
make sure you also educate your
different departments on the importance
of collaboration and explain what your
goals are as well as how they should
work achieving them together next you
need to do your research about the
industry and your audience is at all
like brand24 brand watch or connect
Empire to start monitoring relevant
keywords and gather important
information about your audience
and who exactly solve it the more you
learn at this stage the better equipped
you will be to create the type of
content that your audience wants to see
read or hear customer relationship
management tools are also essential and
they should be used by all of your
different departments not just the
firm's one earlier on I talked a bit
about omni-channel marketing and the
importance of creating a senior's
experience for the customer across
different channels and platforms this is
where a CRM tool comes in to help every
conversations held with a potential
needle customer should be carefully
thought issue of CMT so that whenever
someone from your authority
interacts with them you know exactly
what history the company of the hole has
with that particular prospect will need
to example if someone on a social media
team feels like one of the followers
they've interacted with has potential
they should enter that information in
the CRM tool and make sure the
information gets to the appropriate
person or if a potential customer
contact you by email sharing interest in
your product and then later on follows
your brand on social media then your
social media team need to be made aware
of the possibility to turn a need into a
customer so that they can then engage
them nurture them and move them along
decision-making process there are a lot
of great CRM tools that you can use
therefore
- CRM Zoho CRM and HubSpot CRM social
media is a huge part of digital planning
so it's important to manage it to the
best of your ability posting and
scheduling is easy enough without a tool
but you will need a social media
management tool if you want to make the
most of your effort and save some time
Wow
here's a tool like Agora poll sprout
social or HootSuite to monitor or social
media conversations about your brand and
just have a lead opportunity to engage
users and nurture them to monitor your
social media room and to keep track of
your social media contacts all these
tools allow for team collaboration and
it is very helpful when it comes to
social selling for example if you see a
tweet from someone that looks close to
convert it you couldn't simply a climb a
tree to remember of your sales team to
get them to interact with the prospect
and therefore increase the chances of
them converting plus all proper social
media management tools also offer
monitoring and you can use this feature
to monitor your brand name as well as
other relevant keywords to help you
discover more potentially and interact
with them as soon as possible social
media moves at a very rapid pace so if
you're not there and Reitman you're
effectively losing opportunity but at
all you can keep track of all of your
mention monitored item and so on across
different social media platforms so that
you can respond and acts in a timely
manner
is it another essential tool to have if
you want to enable social digital
filling and there are quite a few
reasons why one of the most important
reasons is that with an integrated
marketing automation tool you can
qualify your leads faster and more
accurately and
we'll convert more of them into
customers when your marketing and sales
department both collaborate and enter
all of their liens interning system
you're creating a much better picture of
the quality of these furthermore
marketing automation is all about
finding the right content at the right
time an essential element of a good
digital selling strategy with a good
marketing automation strategy you can
create personalized content that is
automatically sent to your lien and
prospects at the moment that will
provoke the biggest impact and there are
plenty of great options the marketing
automation tool such as junk food or hot
spots
digital planning and social selling will
continue to evolve and it will most
likely be shaped by new developments in
technology actually a lot of the
technologies there such as artificial
intelligence virtually answered and so
on but now it's a question of when
they're all become accessible enough for
businesses of all shapes and sizes
they're coming here there will likely be
big changes and the type of content and
consume and where and when we can get
them in a few years we might not be
making videos any longer but in massive
virtual reality experiences instead our
audiences might get even more fed up
with all the content or barding them
from all following and we've seen some
amazing developments in personalized
content suggestion and content curation
tool I also believe as more and more
businesses understand the importance of
digital settings they will fight to
create a digital learning department
will this be the end of sales department
marketing departments and so on it's
difficult to say for sure especially at
the range that new technology pops up
after all if this technology that can
completely change the way we do business
just like social media did years ago let
us sum it all up we've learned a few
different things during the course of
this webinar one of the most important
things to get from all of it is that
digital planning is not just the future
if the present digital print it is
sensible not next year not tomorrow but
right now whatever you're selling your
audience is most likely very active on
digital platform because of this your
cell department needs to be more
involved in the marketing process they
need to be involved your social media
presence your company blog and basically
they need to be involved in any and all
content creation processes
are getting more involved in digital and
social selling you can source morally
and more prospects your business nurture
them and turn them into Penn custom law
quickly on the other hand not employing
more digital learning doesn't just mean
you're going to miss opportunities but
there's also a big charm that you'll
stay behind your competitor
to help you gain in latent skills and
digital spend simply Lam offers its
digital spending training this course
follows a blended approach where you'll
complete the course by module while
going through each model you will follow
the following that first paced elearning
videos will introduce the fundamental
concepts and then you'll be able to
apply the knowledge gained into
real-life scenarios using end-of-chapter
projects next you'll be able to intend
instructor-led live classes where these
concepts are built upon and tools
related to these concepts got introduced
all modules focus on different aspects
of digital selling and are packaged our
comprehensive nuggets
focusing on different aspects of a
customer lifecycle and the fair touch
point every touch point must reflect
reinforce as we iterate your core brand
strategy
here's an overview of the training
program the customer life cycle begins
with attracting and engaging the
customer by leveraging digital learning
and a salesperson credibility with
respect to digital training next the
sale person needs to build on his
initial connection by utilizing digital
research and identifying and developing
the digital buyer persona what your work
or familiarize you with a critical step
and best practices to enhance your
digital sales credibility in module 2
you will learn how the visual connection
can then be leveraged to do a
conversation and eventually drive
conversion other practice a third person
needs to be a huge influence in content
marketing and that is essential in
building long term relationships for
clients Phillipa need to know the
content marketing plan in and how it can
be used strategically to increase their
influence over clients these assets will
be covered in detail in module 3
you'll also want to ensure that you
always have a full pipeline while
leveraging the digital skills and assets
at hand is to build a digital selling
strategy in module 4 you learn how you
can find in all the aspects of digital
learning into your digital marketing
effort and gain a competitive edge for
your company
if you're interested to enhance of
selling capabilities or what the deeper
understanding of digital selling you can
involve is training and it includes
salespeople consultant sales
representatives of porno business
development executives and managers
account managers relationship managers
and there is leaving fail team
so what will you get from their training
after completing the training program
you'll be able to understand the
importance of quality content you'll be
able to grow your company online brand
by creating and promoting relevant
content adapter tone style and type of
your content both on your target
audience your use social selling tools
to increase online sales go learn how to
use DRM tool digital tools the social
media platforms to maximize the impact
of your digital and social spending
you'll get in heart social presence and
influence buyer decision you're going to
scale to crimes at all and use your
digital research in tandem with a
tourism platform to target key
decision-makers you capture vital
information for your CRM leverage
advanced digital tool and acquire
relevantly you can reduce lead time and
nurture leads more effectively first
customer retention of CRM sales
intelligent tools
maximize the impact of your digital and
social selling with the use of CRM tool
digital tools and social media plan
[Music]
they're stronger customer engagement
learn what engagement techniques can do
contact into the next here and then how
to handle self objections throughout the
customer journey develop an integrated
selling strategy understand how to lead
and implement a digital barrel strategy
for your organization
thank you so much I'm really looking
forward to your questions and thank you
Rick that was wonderful I always enjoy
them I really enjoy their last one and
this one is just as much yes I do I
really love doing the webinars agenda
for people been around I do the
moderation and a lot of them in the back
although today I had a lot of technology
if you did again they can only sometimes
when they work it's wonderful but when
they do it differently I want a bit of a
backup - yeah you probably dive into the
Q&A we have some questions coming in and
please feel free to add more questions
on there we do have the 15 minutes and
then those we aren't able to get to
yield try to address via email or
through other means so if you have
questions just feel free that under the
Q&A section and disasters in there a
quick announcement we do record all the
session this means that if you go to
simply learn and send them a request
they continue a copy of the session and
that we go back and review a lot of the
stuff that was covered in the session
here so the first question I have coming
up here is from living today I hope I'm
saying that right how to keep ourself
updated as digital marketing is always
changing and this is a really good
question because every time I turn
around I hear a new social media popping
up and then it goes away I mean it would
use differently sorry we keep updated
yes
different digital motion is always
coming up and new things are evolving
all the time the people marketing
industry well I think you know one of
the things I do every day if I spend
time reading different publications
you know everything often going to
conferences and courses and things like
that I think you know sales people or
people in the online world you know you
have to stay up to date and it's a
requirement on my role and there's a lot
of information that there is the case of
knowing where to find it you know
looking at relevant influence of seeing
what people are saying for example at
the moment there's a lot of talk on what
actually you know what's going to be
predicted for 2018 the amount of
requests I've had you know to you know
to join expert roundup my fault you know
in 2018 but it really is the case of
investing in time in learning and
absorbing as much as you can so that
eventually you can hopefully predict
what is going to be happen because
that's the only way inspired X are
excellent and it does seem to be just a
modern times in any industry you really
have to pay up on what's going on today
do you have anything do you have any
particular channels did you like to
follow for keeping up on the latest
digital marketing specific ones that
come to mind
oh goodness I have so many blogs that I
read I mean every day I sign ups a lot
but lots of influences as well and any
high ranking social media examiner good
one most social media tool and online
marketing tool tend to stay up to date
as well as they you'll find that the
content on that blog is very relevant
right up today influences you right you
know for leadership pieces as well
that's another useful place to do I
think it's a case of just dedicating
time every day
and just absorbing as much as possible
and you'll find new ones as well you
know new publications that you can find
it you know just bookmark five or ten
and each day or every couple of days
just you know read through as much
information as you can
okay I'm Sayla another question coming
in from shrieking about the direction
can you please elaborate on omni-channel
marketing so it's like a whole session
you do omni-channel marketing but they
need to do a level umemura and the
omni-channel marketing you brought up
earlier yeah on your channel marketing
is basically when everything is
completely aligned and matched so if for
example you're promoting something on
Facebook then you would have it so there
is a seamless process so that everything
is consistent and matching so it goes
through from Facebook to the emails it's
a very seamless process so sometimes
when you look at a Facebook or an ad or
something and you go to the site
completely not relevant so it's very
compacted all of it into one paper that
seamless process
helped I actually had an article on my
blog about omni-channel marketing was
going to into much more detail and give
ideas of how you can create being as
processes as well
I think followers are the last up and I
we did with you many months ago was on
any channel I remember that yeah I know
I learned a lot from it in fact they
sent a copy of it to my daughter for her
own market basically just making sure
that to consume I have a completely
seamless experience regardless of the
channel or how they found you so just
keep everything very consistent so I got
another question coming in from one deep
it says hi Lila always nice to have that
what are the parameters yeah what is the
promise to evaluate the digital selling
is it always on the ROI so how do you
evaluate your digital selling and how
its hearing I mean you sound all that
really good question I think every
brands and business very different
online so for some companies it's about
raising brand awareness it could be
about generating more traffic affection
others it's very much about a financial
ROI I think that online anything you
doing just you're selling there has to
be financial on my life and that's when
you need to have very powerful tools so
that you can track everything so that
you know where each need comes from and
then whether it converts them you know
so that you can identify what your
conversion rate is or your true ROI
especially if you're investing in
advertising you need to make sure that
you're very hot on those numbers as well
yes correct
excellent no one always challenges me
tracking everything I like to just throw
it out there and hope it works
I'm saying that if you can't measure it
don't do it so if you call any
you do whether it's sending a tweet or
to the post if you have an eye for
measuring habit people don't do it oh
that's a good one
I'm gonna have to write that down to
remind myself you know going out there
blindly you know and I think a lot of
what system setting is we're bringing it
online you know when in the olden days
when we was you know phonebook would
still track things down we would still
work out where people would be different
a lesser but still be able to measure
and monitor and see where our
conversions for coming but for some
reason people went to digital selling
and they forgot about me those old
tactics they were doing and we're doing
well so a lot of it is just common sense
and putting into practice what you've
been doing for years you're flying miles
but moving it the online world No
so some pressures coming in there I know
we have a lot of people who come to
these webinars who are either young or
they're decided whatever they're doing
they don't want to do something
different and so they always come in I'm
not being blind how do you jump into
digital marketing where do you start
if you're new to it and this is the
career you want to switch to because it
looks interesting it would you start on
that is something completely new to
digital marketing recommend that you
invest in you know sneakers courses so
that you can learn and get up to speed
as quickly as possible
I'll also you know and a lot of time
reading and absorbing as much content as
there is out there go to conferences
meet people as well
and just start experimenting start
creating some really good content make
sure that you have a blog as well and
think about what your what your
objectives are you know there's no point
just following because they're people is
doing it you need to think about what
what you actually want to achieve and
then I think it came from creating a
strategy and working backwards how
you're going to meet their projection
hmm that's funny Mike that's good advice
and then let's go to the other side of
that for some of us older people I work
with small businesses and one of the
things that I saw over the years there's
a business to come from the old model
you know there is their team out there
making phone calls and they're just
going to switch to the digital marketing
and I witnessed system in a number of
companies is almost a battle between the
sales team and the digital marketing the
visual marketing is automated so there's
often uses or Commission and then the me
tries to take the Commission away and
make non-commissioned can you see this
continual juggling with a large with the
companies are going to work the small
and medium size company what would be
your answer for that transition I don't
know how much you've been exposed to
that kind of transition more than me as
well there's a real yeah they're not
connected at all hopefully I think
companies have a choice you know if they
want to continue staying afoot if they
want to evolve and move forward they
have to adapt and they have to educate
their team to sensible work together so
that everybody is aligned I need to
incentivize each person for that reason
and ultimately if people aren't prepared
to adapt they have to let them go you
know if they're not right the company
you know obviously that would be a last
thing but I think it's ultimately about
education people have scared
human being we're very conventional
people and we don't like often new
things you know they're very like doing
what we currently do and we don't always
adapt to change well and it's about
encouraging staff to first of all work
together but also to embrace the change
to look forward to it and to enjoy it
and companies need to do it in a way
that makes people respond and engage
them so that they feel part of it but
ultimately it has to happen all
companies work for many as well and if
they don't they won't you know it's a
lot of technophiles but there's ways
around it and you know technology
regardless of the age person you know
people can enjoy it can be fun my mom
now loves doing you know things but you
know it's funny seeing it but and I
think that's how companies have to deal
with it and you have to take it on board
each person and try and make it a fun
way for them so that they don't hate it
and they don't feel it because generally
people don't enjoy something when
they're not very good at it so if we can
educate them and help them become really
amazing that's it then they want embrace
it much more and enjoy it and it will
benefit the company every one of them
self excellent excellent
and let's continue on along the lines of
companies what would you suggest for a
company small to medium sized company
use Eli's companies are very different
than again getting profit in a small and
medium-sized company how would you
suggest for them if they're moving from
an older model they look at their team
if they're all on the same page what
would you suggest for the company of you
as a whole I think again it's very
similar it's down to having training
education making sure that they have the
most effective tools that they have good
team collaboration tools as well making
sure that the message from the top is
pivoted all the way down so that
everybody understands why this is
happening they're showing them as well
because a lot comes a lot of dark and
nervous it may mean that be out of work
or whatever as I think it's just I think
communication is so in communication and
education and the two key things and I
think if you get that right you won't
have any issues but it company a need to
invest the time in educating people so
that they can use these tools
effectively because tools there's so
many powerful tools available now to
help with digital sign but these tools
are only as good as the people who are
using them and that's where things
sometimes get messy
that's my experience and there's gonna
be a mascot and have you any question
isn't so much is the nuff coming but
when and how can you deal with it and
you take care of it communication if you
go back to the questions how can you
assume that all conversations with the
customer or laws and all the departments
have access to them what kind of tools
or what can we do to make sure that
communications up and running yeah so
you need to make sure that you have a
really strong CRM system in place and
again it boils down to having some level
of trust with your team incentive to
ensure that they spend the time to love
everything but effectively it's learning
how to use these tools well so that
everything is tracked but it beings can
only assign to the next person the whole
process needs to be automated as
possible
yeah so it's basically a case of
leveraging the tools making sure that
there's no one tool that does it all
because often you need multiple
different tools from collaboration to
the CRM side of things and that tools
are becoming very very advanced now the
technology that we have today
you know I review so many tools and I'm
just amazed by it when you think of five
years ago what is now available is
incredible so I think it's just a case
of making sure that staff are trained as
well as possible so they can maximize
their tools and consolidate all that
information and refine it into the
relevant people that's all we have time
for maybe one or two more questions if
you have
you'll see the post them I have one up
here if we don't have a budget for
digital marketing that's in trouble then
a bunch of additional marketing today is
there anything we can do what budget
don't you have you know because
everybody if you're in business you have
to find the money in digital marketing
and you're talking advertising are you
talking to pay somebody to help you
create content how many staff do you
have do you have the resources in how to
do it so that you can you know create
content and start marketing out there's
lots of different variables to the whole
budget thing if you have a nice budget
and you're one person then it's ticking
whereas if you have no budget but you've
got 10 20 people that can help and you
can leverage the time for them but I
would always start off with content and
content is the hub of everything
content is where you can promote so you
know across social media without context
we are doing is growing and you need to
have that mix of content in the middle
there but you meet you need a budget you
know you can't you need to be able to
pay for software tools even the most
basic ones you need to have you know
necessarily need a paint budget for
advertising but it really depends on
your audience on how they give your
following on Twitter or Facebook etc how
engaged are that there's so many
variables to that it's hard to be
specific in my own hmm excellent that
does bring us to the end of the hour I
really appreciate you coming with us
today to join us as we learn and and
again a reminder you do record these
sessions so you can go into something
learn calm and request a copy if you
want or if you have more questions on
simply learn there's a an open chat we
can talk to people on there and if for
some reason you didn't get me you have a
question that comes up later on which
happens a lot at least for me it does
you feel free to go into the community
we learn calm and there's forums there
that you can post those questions in
there or you can send a note that simply
learnin ask the question and we'll try
to address those and bring those back
that's all we work for today Levi could
you have any last comments you want to
make before we go ahead and sign off no
I just think you know actually it's all
about taking action end of the day so we
all attend many webinars and let me go
off and carry on us on our day to day
things so I'd always recommend that you
take some notes and just do one thing
each day which is going to generate
power just one thing every day
oh I
that advice good advice for us one step
at a time to get there right and if we
only be one thing each day it will make
a big difference
well thank you very much for being here
and with that we'll go ahead and we're
very happy learning and hopefully see
you in our classrooms
again visit simply learn comm let us
know I feel free to post on your social
channels
hashtag SL simply learn SL webinars for
your hash bill my gosh hey my tongue
gets tied suddenly at the end you'll see
the posterior half say yes tell webinars
to let people know that you came here
and you add notes on there we always
appreciate that and we wish you a
wonderful evening morning afternoon
depending on where your ash hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos de nerd up
and get certified click here